I know welcome to this video playing
chess spritz don't know this guy I
meaning i never played him and okay
let's play in a classic away will you
six get some catalan or a righty system
what do we get a ready system okay i go
away five a couple of possible ways to
play this with black this is one of them
just get the a pawn going and let's
fianchetto now I try to play this with
look at this game Lucky's I would 44
it's a bit of an annoying idea yeah I
can do this it looks a little bit
unconventional but not on before it's
not a bad square maybe I could have gone
night a six actually that would have
been a little bit more more flexible
can I go D for you is that strategically
too risky hmm might be but I get Bishop
c5 next actually
that could be interesting let's try it
it's a bit risky and I said because that
pawn can can can be exposed be exposed a
little bit but we'll see but I'm in this
pin no it's also yeah this but I have
night to before him i think i'm happy
with this being traded
okay the question is C 5 do I want to do
this in my night now also because of
that discovery
yeah that so much for playing quicker um
okay let's prove it prepare c5 him
that is also 97 so that our 97-94 f5 and
the night has no squares so it has to go
back to f3 I think no maybe five in that
central space
hmm shooting for nights it to wangs
maybe I can reroute the night on the
seven won't go in anyway
okay bishops III here or not I even look
up anyway not sure that that helps yeah
I mean Bishop d3 i'm not sure that it
helped helped me in some way
that's a good move unfortunately light
xe5 is a threat ham
I end up going there anyway it's tricky
a queen queen bee one community oh okay
I was more afraid of that Queen maneuver
but queen bee three are also not not bad
light is potentially good here in this
position at least in some cases that can
be better than my bishop when it comes
to attacking my pawns can be an issue
I might be able to go see if I actually
and then 95 I have some back rank issues
now came but it can be okay c5 King g8
no egos they immediately
check no seagoing night to e6
night f7 I can take is no made down this
one
hmm cannot take the rook unfortunately
but I can maybe take the rook after 9 to
e six chicks ignite f8 am i checkmated
there I mean I have quite some counter
play rook f6 that's okay 8 ok so I'm
going to take it I can check here and
time how always have to this you can
draw I don't see how I can avoid that
anymore check match is six is a draw of
course ok ok maybe 25 I hoped his
covering f3 he's covering f3 haha that
is setting set is very unfortunate now I
think I have to do this right it's no
other way ping ghs chatter madness nice
King is much much better now that's
going to be very difficult to play
ah Wow check it was kind of surprising
end that you under the Sun could cover
everything check check check check wind
is on time or draw yes to fight for that
role check you get it ok check black for
face on time yeah ok that was tricky all
of a sudden he could cover stuff with
Queen f5 ok so that means that this
whole operation was most faulty yeah all
in all was a difficult position this was
kind of ok here i think and maybe around
here i'm starting to drift a little bit
because the Queen it doesn't really
belong they're only six and now ya hear
maybe I should just take that pawn I
mean I was I didn't really evaluate this
right check yeah this is a funny move
just justice 96 also seems to be good
now it is just just amazing that yeah
okay computer wants to go see six year
and jack yeah this is this is what I
overlooked when I went for Queen takes a
for that that f3 is covered and he
threatening this at the same time this
is just my bishop is not not playing
this is why I was reluctant to put it on
on c3 in the first place but when we had
the position I didn't really know what
else to do ok I can do like f6 something
yeah maybe I should do something like
that f6 that's what the computer
suggests something like this and this
this or f5 here it still feels wrong to
me to have that Bishop out there in the
open yeah that wasn't a really good game
ok thanks for watching